francis haugen is a former facebook
employee
last year she revealed how the company
was failing to tackle disinformation
hate speech and mental health issues
she told meps new legislation to reign
in big tech needs to be robust
the law has to be strong and its
enforcement firm
otherwise we will lose this once in a
generation opportunity to align the
future of technology and democracy
the digital services act that is now
before this parliament has the potential
to be a global gold standard
this gold standard will include tough
new rules to ensure a safer online
environment
measures to counter illegal or malicious
content products and services as well as
strict controls on the algorithms that
suggest content based on users behavior
we are fighting for those who uses the
platforms we are trying to take back
control we need to really see
real
improvements in the protection of
consumers and citizens online and we
need to make sure that we still protect
the fundamental rights for instance the
right to speak freely at the same time
the digital markets act will tackle
unfair business practices it will help
startups and smaller companies grow
alongside established giants the
so-called gatekeepers of the internet
smaller businesses will get a much
easier access to the market to reach out
to the consumer you as a consumer will
also be in a better position because you
see all the variety of the market and
you catch what you want and that's
excellent
the rules will cover core platforms like
social networks search engines video
sharing services and cloud computing
they include new limits on targeted
advertising and give consumers the
option to remove pre-installed software
the proposed new frameworks provided by
the digital services act and digital
markets act will also include
protections for whistleblowers as europe
looks to defend democratic values and
fair competition and promote a safer
online world